we now have a title for the new animated
Babylon 5 movie Welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so as we told you on the channel last
week Jay Michael skaginski has written
and created an animated movie in
conjunction with Warner Brothers I told
you at that time that actually the
original cast or the surviving original
cast were returning and that this movie
would be based around the original
Babylon 5 series not the new reimagined
series that maybe would have made sense
in some ways for them to do an animated
movie before the release of that
reimagined project but no it would be
based around the original Babylon 5. now
I was actually told by my sources that
this project was called Homewood it's
not but they were very close it's
actually called the road home
it will be based around the 1990s
television series and it will have these
actors returning Bruce Brock's liner
will return as John Sheridan Claudia
Christensen as Ivanova Peter Jurassic as
malari I love milari is one of my
favorite actors Bill mummy as a linear
uh Tracy Scoggins as Elizabeth lockley
and Patricia Tallman as Lita Alexander
zazinski wrote the moving and executive
producers Matt Peters known for the
Batman Superman Battle of the sun's
direct and Matt Morales serving a
supervising producer Sam register is the
executive producer on the project
voices also include Paul Goya as zathras
and Jennifer Sinclair Anthony Hansen as
Michael Garibaldi Mara Juno as a
reporter and computer voice Phil a Lamar
as Dr Stephen Franklin piyota Michael as
David Sheridan
and Andrew Morgado as jakar Rebecca
Reedy as Dylan obviously voicing the
characters of some of the actors that
sadly passed away
now first of all what do we think about
this well if this is successful and I
suspect it will be Jay Michael zazinski
said actually this could become a series
of animated movies based in and around
the period of the Babylon 5 Series so we
get to fill in some of the gaps now
obviously
Sheridan's story arc was pretty much
well told but there were quite large
time jumps within the five seasons of
Babylon 5. so there is lots of story to
tell we can actually see other battles
from the shadow conflict potentially or
oh a million other storylines so yeah I
am pretty excited about this but guys
I'd love you to get into the comments
and tell me what you think is this a
project you're excited about is this
something you would love to see a series
of animated movies about are you happy
that they've re-voiced and recast some
of the actors that slashed away
I think it's a shame but to be honest I
think those actors would have loved this
project to happen so I don't think
they'd have minded if they were asked
which obviously they haven't been but
really
I'd love to know exactly what you're
thinking so get in the comments as
always please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos as we try to get the Sci-Fi news
out to you as quickly as we can also go
to patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for some more
contribution each month that really
helps out the channel you don't have to
watch the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll
catch you next time
foreign foreign
[Music]